Trascrizione: Nicola Perantoni
Revisore: Federico Sangati
Ho sempre avuto un rapporto
molto fisico con le cose,
con tutti gli oggetti che mi circondano.
Fin da bambino ricordo
la magia delle forme, dei colori,
le sensazioni che mi regalavano al tatto.
D'altronde, crescendo con un padre artista
il rapporto con la materia
è sempre stato enfatizzato e valorizzato.
Rapidamente sviluppai
una passione per gli oggetti,
quasi un'ossessione.
Non per qualunque oggetto,
ma solo per quelli belli!
Non c'era una ragione ben precisa:
era una cosa di pancia,
che veniva da dentro.
Il mio rapporto con gli oggetti
era estremamente intimo.
In pochi secondi li smontavo
per vedere come fossero fatti all'interno,
ma non sempre riuscivo a ricomporli.
Una volta smontati, sezionati, analizzati,
li mettevo da parte:
per me erano archiviati.
Ormai sapevo tutto, non avevano segreti.
Col tempo questo mi permise
di creare una certa banca dati,
una conoscenza personale
degli oggetti abbastanza estesa;
e anche di sviluppare
alcune capacità manuali
relative all'uso
di utensili e materiali vari.
Un'altra cosa che mi ha sempre affascinato
è vedere le persone lavorare,
lavorare con le proprie mani.
Gli artigiani, in particolare.
L'artigiano perfeziona il suo gesto
grazie alla ripetizione dell'azione.
La scelta del giusto utensile,
la mano ferma, lo stile;
d'altronde sono capacità che si allenano,
un po' come la matematica,
o il disegno o le lingue.
Ma proprio perché
si tratta di un allenamento
è fondamentale cominciare quanto prima
ad allenare le proprie mani,
a sentire la fiducia nelle proprie mani.
È una cosa che da bambini
facciamo abbastanza quotidianamente
e in maniera naturale
ma crescendo, spesso,
può passare in secondo piano.
E questo può rappresentare
delle difficoltà
e poca fiducia in se stessi
nel trasformare le proprie idee in realtà.
Le idee, soprattutto appena nate,
sono fragili, effimere.
Hanno bisogno di molta cura e mano ferma,
per essere trasformate in realtà.
È proprio lì che è necessario sviluppare
la propria conoscenza di se stessi
e la propria fiducia per procedere
e trasformare le idee in oggetti fisici.
Spesso, la prima
materializzazione di un oggetto,
la prima realizzazione fisica,
è un prototipo.
E non sempre i prototipi
si presentano in questo ordine,
in ordine logico
e in maniera pulita o ordinata.
Si tratta semplicemente
di provare alcune assunzioni,
e verificarle per poi
procedere alla successiva.
La maggior parte delle volte
si presentano più come un'accozzaglia
di cose, scotch, filo di ferro
e tanta pazienza.
Ma è proprio in momenti come questi
che ci si può sentire liberi
di pensare con le proprie mani.
Questo che vedete piccolo
giallo in basso a destra
è stato il primo modellino
del mio progetto
di carrello-valigia per bicicletta.
Risale a sette anni fa.
Quello che vedete alle spalle
è stato il primo prototipo,
due anni più giovane.
Dico prototipo, perché
la caratteristica del prototipo
è di essere almeno
parzialmente funzionante.
Dico almeno parzialmente,
perché effettivamente
quello si ruppe abbastanza rapidamente.
Però diciamo che per
qualche metro funzionò!
Ricordo quando scattai questa foto.
Fui piuttosto soddisfatto.
Ero nel mezzo della Svezia
con i miei amici,
i miei compagni di viaggio,
e finalmente un prototipo funzionante.
Eravamo passati da qualche metro
a più di mille chilometri.
In realtà ricordo anche bene
come al rientro, dopo qualche settimana,
mi resi conto di quanto
fossi lontano dal mio obiettivo,
lontano dall'oggetto
che volevo realizzare.
E fu lì che, in seguito
all'ennesima discussione,
persi i miei compagni
di viaggio e di progetto,
e persi anche un po'
fiducia nella mia idea.
Fu un piccolo fallimento, in realtà.
Ma è proprio in momenti come quello
che è ancora più necessario
continuare a metterci le mani davvero
per sentirsi sempre più liberi
di sbagliare rapidamente,
imparare dai propri errori
e crescere da questi.
Prima o poi, col tempo e con la passione,
i risultati si ottengono sempre.
Spesso sono diversi da come
ce li eravamo aspettati all'inizio,
da come ce li eravamo immaginati,
ma questa fa parte della magia
del processo creativo.
La vera difficoltà, certe volte,
è capire quando un progetto
è arrivato al traguardo,
quando un progetto è finito.
Dopo un po' di anni
di esperienza come designer,
sinceramente la mia esperienza
è che i progetti non si finiscono mai,
ma si abbandonano a un certo punto.
Ed è necessario fare ciò
per lasciarli liberi di andare nel mondo.
Altrimenti, il rischio [è]
di mantenerli solo per sé,
[e] continuare a iterare
nel tentare di perfezionare un oggetto
e alla fine non presentarlo mai al mondo.
La mia sfida è proprio crescere
passando all'oggetto successivo
passando al progetto successivo.
Yvon Chouinard,
fondatore di Patagonia,
è l'imprenditore che mi ha più stimolato
nel fondare la mia startup,
a intraprendere
questo lavoro da imprenditore.
Il suo approccio radicale, ma sostenibile,
al prodotto e al progetto,
mi hanno folgorato
e mi hanno fatto capire quanto
il prodotto e il progetto stessi
possano giovare dall'approccio
imprenditoriale, e viceversa.
Ora, mi rendo conto
che parlare di startup e di design
possano essere passioni
non condivise da tutti qui.
Ma è proprio lì che vi sfido
a cercare le vostre passioni,
ad analizzarle, a cercare le vostre idee,
trattarle con cura,
trasformarle in progetti,
quindi in prototipi e quindi in oggetti.
Trasformare le vostre idee in realtà,
mettendoci le mani veramente.
Come fanno queste persone,
quotidianamente:
sporcandosi le mani
per innovare nel mondo della cucina;
o come qualcuno fa, scalando montagne
e facendo imprese al limite
delle loro capacità fisiche e mentali.
O come fanno moltissimi
coraggiosi di noi
che cercano di creare un futuro nuovo
per la propria famiglia.
Quello che veramente conta
è trovare le proprie passioni,
dedicarci il giusto tempo
e intraprenderle.
Non c'è momento migliore
del qui ed ora per farlo.
Le vostre passioni possono essere
la migliore scusa in assoluto
per creare dei nuovi progetti.
Da passioni di persone comuni
sono nate le idee che hanno
cambiato il nostro mondo.
Pertanto, come ci ricordano
Charles e Ray Eames,
prendete seriamente le vostre passioni!
Grazie!
(Applausi)